What's up guys, we're Pongfinity!
Today we're playing a match to 21 points,
and after each point we'll be adding one peace of clothing.
This is gonna get sweaty!
Good luck! Good luck!
We have chosen the hottest day of Finnish summer to films this video.
If you don't sweat enough in normal table tennis, this will get you sweaty!
Allright, so the first item, the brand new Sensei t-shirt!
I'm looking forward to putting this on!
Yess!
Doubleshorts! I don't think I've ever done this before.
Sensei is still cooled down here.
No I'm not!
Making the Sensei move for a change.
I'm not feeling too happy about putting more clothes on.
Next point I'm going to lose on purpose!
Nice one!
Noo I don't want to win the point!
But yes it's a Pongfinity bandana I can get this off.
Where can you get this?
pongfinity.store
Aaah good old Pongfinity bandana.
Oh no I missed!
You get to put some clothes on!
I'll put my favorite Sensei t-shirt, the purple one.
That looks very nice!
It's my favorite color.
You can get yours from fanjoy.co/pongfinity.
Sensei!
Oh no this is the worst!
I hope you guys are more excited to put this on
when you get it from our store than what I am to put it on now!
This is where the nightmare starts!
But the design is very cool.
*Evil laugh*
Tactic is working perfectly!
I don't know what I'm doing!
Second pair of shorts.
Yeah no problem.
Three t-shirts on.
Now he wasn't trying to get it on, he just wanted to slap me.
My favorite t-shirt!
Who remembers this?
Comment which video this t-shirt has been used in.
Miikka's favorite shot!
The t-shirt works!
Or actually...
It's got the breathing hole.
No!
Sensei with the bandana.
Bravo bravo!
Looking good!
Now that I have warmed up I can start doing the footwork.
Lets see that!
I couldn't take it serious!
He looks like he's in a gang or something.
It's a bit tight from here but...
This one is going to be fun.
My favorite underpants!
What? What are you laughing at Otto?
Nothing.
You got a problem with my outfit?
No, no I don't.
Time for some more merch!
This is turning out to be a great advert for our clothing.
Pongfinity cap.
It suits you this whole outfit quite well.
Especially this one.
Yeah!
Miikka's new summer look!
Yeah summer 2021, this is the look to go for!
That's why you never play with a cap on!
I think that's a point for me.
Look at him!
I wouldn't want to face Otto on a dark street!
Ooh the underpants.
He's not so scary anymore!
But again like in a weird way it actually suits you.
Thank you!
Or actually it doesn't.
This is going to ruin my fashion look.
Now you look like a baseball player or something.
Ooh. The backhand flip is going well today.
Looking good!
Scared to serve anything now!
Look at Otto.
Throwback to the sumo suit video.
I feel the same.
Sorry!
My favorite one.
Oh my god I can't see anything.
Okay if my footwork isn't fast now then it will never be fast.
I can't see the ball!
Okay lets even it out.
Enough of showing off the classes Otto, I'm getting a bit hot.
You want to put some more clothes on?
I'd gladly put some more clothes on.
Noo how can I miss that!
Around the net glasses.
Around the net vision.
I see like a digital screen like ,  *dididi* now!
Buy them from pongfinity.store!
Maybe in twenty years.
Oh now you're matching like brothers!
Uuh nice!
Oh tie!
Nice purple tie as well.
Otto do you want to come and tie it for me?
Feel like I'm going to a big event, suiting up.
A very weird Christmas party.
I don't know who would organize this sort of Christmas party.
Oh no, this is where it gets bad.
I mean my legs are already soking wet.
This is my least favorite item so far.
Look at this, see the swet?
Serve!
I want to get this over with.
I wanted to make him forehand loop.
Almost the same color.
I mean it has to matching clothing.
It's so hard to see the ball!
Noo!
Just remember Otto we haven't even got to the winter jackets yet.
I know.
Yes!
Double hat time.
I don't want to loop.
Unless you give me a...
Unless I give you an easy spot.
I hope the next item will be like a refrigerator or something.
Ooh the scarf is loose!
Oh no!
Good chop block.
Thanks.
Aah yes.
It doesn't look very breathable.
You're like really colorful.
Yeah I've got a little everything.
Sorry.
It's getting warm enough.
I'll actually close the jacket.
I'll do that too cause there's so many things swinging around.
Yeah now it's better.
Never been this hot in my whole life.
Sorry!
All that work for nothing!
Look at this trickshot.
No.
Okay that's going to make it hard.
You look like you're prepared for like the harshest winter season.
Only backahnd block from now on, nothing else.
Yeah looking forward to these.
I was getting a bit cold in the hands.
What a shot!
I feel like there's swet dripping on my upper lip.
Not so fun anymore.
How was this supposed to...
I'll put it on you.
Get your playing position I'll dress it up for you.
I dont trust you.
I'll tuck it in here.
He's got like a tail!
Give us a wiggle Otto.
Wiggle wiggle wiggle!
Come on Otto!
It feels a bit dangerous.
Maybe you put it like on your waist.
You tied his legs!
That was on purpose!
I don't want to put another jacket on.
No problem it's just a motorcycle jacket.
Come on!
Good match!
Finally it's over!
Good match.
And the new Sensei collection with this really cool design
is now available at the Fanjoy link below.
Go get yours from there!